my friends
i have a white white white pill means
like optimism yes yeah yeah optimism
despite uh all indications that your
optimism is crazy yeah that's how i
understand that gandalf fighting the
what was that that demon that he fought
on the bridge
he took the white pill i think that's
why he came back as the white wizard oh
i wonder if that's where the reference
stems from interesting no probably not
it's just because like dark and light
yeah
which is funny because it goes back to
um just night and day
the during the day it's warm you're safe
you can see at night it's dark and the
predators are lurking you can't see them
so humans associated the two anyway
anyway
i have good news for you
uh i think that it is likely we will see
gavin newsom uh be recalled
and when that happens larry elder is
likely to win and i have uh one bit of
evidence to back that come up now
this is definitive proof you need only c
i'm building up suspense here once you
see what i'm about to show you
everyone's prizes are saying there's
like i don't believe it there's none of
though you once you see this you're
gonna be he won larry other one
all right you guys ready yes we have
this tweet from jean guerrero uh she is
a columnist for the la times
she said get ready for this one
democratic outreach to latino voters on
the california recollection is not
working i've been speaking to young
latinxes and almost none of them have
any idea what's going on this is really
really bad
almost none of the ones i've spoken to
have any idea what's going on
um okay so let me let me break down for
you why i think this is good news
if this lady from the l.a times goes to
a young latino person and calls them a
la tinx they're going to be like this
lady's crazy
they probably have no idea what she's
talking about
we got we got some new uh staffers here
at the house and you know they don't
know who aoc is
they don't know who brett kavanaugh is
and i'm like those are good things
perfect you know i'm not trying to tell
you who they are we're just talking
about you know the state of politics and
they're like we don't we don't know i'm
like great great do your job
everything's great you don't got to
worry about these people regular people
don't know what latinx is
and so this shows you something powerful
the democratic establishment is
absolutely psychotic
there are people in the l.a times going
like the latinxes aren't voting for us
and the people are like i don't know
what that is
so if they're going to start making
phone calls
i'm looking for to speak with the are
you latinx
latinx
is latinx that's just
hardcore in me i don't know but you know
like because the s at the end like the
tink's oh it's latinx s yeah there's an
s at the end and that's at the end
latinxes la tinxes la tinxes it can't be
la tinxes imagine it's not
imagine someone you know calling you for
all the people who are out there who
like who are i'm sure the people who
watch this show they've heard these
words before
but imagine your mom or your grandma
like you're latino and they get a call
and like hi are you the tinx the t-next
they're going to be like what is that
that means why is this genderless lap
yeah it's so insane how would you do
that in french
oh they haven't got that far yet they
don't have to worry about the french
voters just wait just wait french voters
well there's northern maine okay the
northernmost point of maine is french
french america then you've got the
nollens
how are you gonna how are you gonna get
how do you how do you degender french
no idea you could say
l-e-a
licks so it's like a cross between la
and la no it's just licks lx lx
[Laughter]
we are silly people all the romance
languages are gendered
right they're all gendered right yeah
yeah italian
yeah yeah spanish and french for sure
portuguese german is german that's true
that's not a language but yeah these
people did not think this through they
didn't think this through just but but
think about this this means that the
democratic establishment is isolated in
this bubble where regular people are not
and although regular people you know
default liberals will vote democrat
they're not looking at this the same way
the establishment is so when the la
times comes out and screams larry elder
is the black face of white supremacy
regular people go
who
i'm still saying that tell me about this
guy i don't know hopefully i'll meet him
soon or get to talk to him larry elder
yeah yeah he's great is he cool
i should look into it i haven't said
much about it because
he's really sharp yeah he he actually
had a a tv program that he did a few
times a week at the epoch times so i'm
pretty familiar with him because you
know i saw him a couple times and you
know i'm i've watched his stuff and he's
very big on uh thomas soule you know the
the economist he i think he was a mentor
to him he's very big on um instead of
pointing at something like systemic
racism for problems in the back in the
black community he'll point out the fact
that you know
a large portion of black community
doesn't have fathers in the home you
know so he has some traditional
conservative values but at least they're
sane you know i mean he's not out there
you know saying lettings is like
like drunk dr seuss you know i mean
he actually says things that that are
grounded and are reasonable even if you
disagree with them you know but no i i
larry elder would make a really
interesting addition to the california
government i i think aside from that um
getting a change in california yes just
just for once
it's like um you know
i'll put it this way california is like
if someone
took it to you know kept using a toy
without flushing
and it's just a mess ew and larry elder
will will be the flush yeah you know
what i mean like he's he's going to be
the person to come in and like and then
just take his foot up and then pull the
lever down and finally just he might
find he's the guy that needs the shovel
and needs to shovel all the poop out so
that there's enough room for it to flush
totally oh this reminds me though that
uh this this video did not get nearly
enough coverage gavin newsom cleaning up
at berkeley did you know
that yeah oh man that was great he
looked like the petulant 12 year old kid
that's having to help his grandpa like
clear out lumber he's like pitching it
he's got this awful like you know face
on him it's so funny so that's that's
how he cleans up california petulantly
and angry like an elitist but larry
elder would actually come in and do some
serious work
that's what i'm saying about these
people who just want power they don't
want to do work right they don't want to
gavin newsom's like
he was probably sitting in his office
and they were like okay gavin look this
recall's a big deal there's a lot of
people who want to vote you out we need
to do something to show the public
you're there for them and he's like i
could give a speech and they're like no
no you got to get your hands dirty
excuse me excuse me
we're good i'm thinking
why don't we go clean up
i thought i thought for a minute you
said you want me
to go clean up
their mess
we gotta connect with people i won't do
it and then like some guy said gavin you
gotta do it or you're done he's like oh
fine and he's like uh that's how i
imagine it
yeah and then he shows up and he's like
make me clean
that's exactly that's the total vibe he
was given off in that video and i don't
think it had sound but you could just
see it on his face he was just like why
am i doing this this is beneath me but
think about it's like you know there are
people who work hard every day
construction and labor and and you know
medical professionals
this guy what does he do
he just he
california is just
awful like where were you and you were
in orange county yeah orange in orange
county but prior to that i was in uh the
uh the san fernando valley in l.a oh
okay okay yeah uh and and that that's
that's got a lot of problems too still
not as bad as like san francisco with
the homelessness and the poop patrols
and stuff
uh no i mean it's it's still got
problems i mean homelessness is a
serious problem i mean i'll i'll never
forget i was standing on my patio uh
this is probably six months ago and when
they were releasing prisoners from the
prisoner you know and i saw two police
cars pull up they released a prisoner he
signed his papers at the bus stop then
we locked eyes and i went back inside
huh wow like yeah it's because of the
covet stuff
yeah i'm assuming i mean maybe it was
just like a standard drop off but it was
at the same time that i was hearing oh
we're still releasing prisoners you know
in drives so uh yeah i mean it's
california has problems it's statewide
it's not necessarily uh you know pockets
this is crazy to see this look tink's
assistant yeah no because i'm like i got
to be honest like i was talking about we
were mentioning mentioning this with joe
biden that even though i know joe biden
isn't with it like it's fairly obvious i
still believe there was some control
you know i'm like oh joe biden's out of
it but the system is in is is working
right like it's maybe maybe in a
weakened state but it's still there
now with afghanistan i'm just like there
is no system there is no president there
is it is just it is just absolute case i
look at this thing with the democrats
and i'm like there's no plan these
people have genuinely gone insane as
much as i rag on them i always kind of
felt like the wholeness was was planned
coordinated like they knew what they
were doing to manipulate light sheet and
steel this woman shows you
they don't
they've they've eaten their own refuse
that that toilet's full they're eating
out of it
they believe the crap they're put
they're filling up in these toilets
i guess it's a good thing though right
i don't know well it means like regular
people aren't in that world
that's a good thing but that i guess
i'll put it this way
people keep voting for it because they
think republicans are bad
oh well you know republicans are kind of
bad the two-party system is yeah
stripping people of their
of their choice
whether they realize it or not people
feeling like the lesser of two evils man
that drives me crazy that phrase lesser
of two evils i've heard it for like 20
years people want to vote for the lesser
of two
dude yeah we're not even there anymore
now it's like you can vote for nothing
or for a toilet full of
of crap huh the democratic party is like
piling up a toilet and the republicans
are not going to flush it
so it's like you can vote for the guys
who at least won't stack up on it or you
can vote for the guys who are going to
stack up on it it's like
that's what we get what do you do like
i can't take a 78 year old in the seven
dave you read my mind that's exactly
what i was going to say i mean because
he analyzed the situation
pretty thoroughly not too long ago he
was talking about how you know we're
looking at a very strong possibility in
2024 where it's kamala harris versus
donald trump and he's like if this plays
out
it's a very interesting opportunity for
a third-party candidate not going to say
me but you know but that's that was his
point and i really think that might be
the case i mean i'd like to think that
would happen but i mean won't they just
uh we can we can manifest it right ian
we have a lot of power we can do it just
by thinking and meditating
talking about it on tv like every i love
calling this tv by the way television um
yeah let's use the but i think if we the
more we talk about it like it has
compounding effects we can definitely
help manifest
i think uh
man it's tough because trump's
i i i don't think trump
man trump's tough
because his character defects are an
issue
but his policy you know what he wanted
to do
was
pretty good
like his second term agenda i like
school choice was big uh banning
critical race theory in contracts it's a
violation of lawyer way do it getting
our troops out of the middle east and
things like that
i'm for it getting our manufacturing
back you know uh i'm i'm for it
protecting our borders i'm for it
but trump's character plays an issue now
i've never felt that his character was
like the guy could say the stupidest
things in the world if he's doing a good
job then fine you know would you rather
have a plumber who can't you know you
got two plumbers one guy's falling
asleep and can't speak straight the
other guy is cussing like a sailor but
manny can fix some pipes you know which
one do you hire
2024
if we get
maybe a third party option i might
consider it
yeah well but the thing that worries me
about trump though is that we saw
it's not just like he was the plumber
that was swearing up and down and was
able to actually fix the problem
people like
the machine got in his way and prevented
him from fixing the problem right you
know so i mean isn't that just going to
happen again is it going to be you know
russiagate 2.0 and i mean how how strong
is this machine that's going to prevent
him from actually ins in instigating
these policies that he wants to do yeah
that's why i've been saying like
desantis is probably better than trump
because trump is one of the most
polarizing candidates we've ever had
right and desantis will get smeared like
they're doing it to larry elder but
they're not gonna be able to smear him
nearly as much as they did with trump
because trump had had
uh prominent personality and clips and
people ate it up desantis doesn't have
the the history of donald trump speaking
or anything like this they're gonna
they're probably already working on you
know they're doing apple research like
crazy right now
now the thing about dave smith because
you know we had him on last friday and
we're big fans uh michael mal's press
secretary yeah that's all i want to say
that's all i want to say it would you
know what man i can laugh about it
but i genuinely think america needs
a michael mal's press secretary we know
that leads to michael mallon's vice
presidency
no no he's presidency
yeah was he born in the u.s
i think he wasn't so he can't be
president
if he's press secretary he's not going
to be vice president no no eventually
he'll just get his feet he'll learn the
system and then in 2032 i don't think he
can be i don't know michael mouse i want
to see him deal with the press yeah
that's all i want to say i mean i think
you said the other night that he would
just run circles around these people
yeah that's an understatement exactly
exactly they would be sitting there
they're like their heads would start
spinning and then just like it would be
like the final scene in kingsman while
their head would blow up
yeah yeah that would that would be uh
that would be amazing but imagine what
the american people would finally hear
if you got
someone like michael to just you know to
be saying to be speaking
that's almost more important in my
opinion than the presidency itself
because we don't hear from joe biden
every day we hear from gentecki we
didn't hear from trump every day we
heard from you know spicer or or kaylee
and uh they did a pretty good job um
kelly mcinney was fantastic when she
pulled the book and she like let me fact
check you journal and she had all the
articles to fact check them brilliant
the thing about michael though is
he would add a level
of mockery yes and disdain and derision
that would be unparalleled a level of
malice if you will
exactly exactly built right into the
name that's a beautiful thing
yeah
well one can hope i suppose we can
manifest it i'll put it this way
i'm my my biggest fear always with these
things is that people are going to be
like a third party can never win so just
support the republicans and i'm like
well that's why they'll never win
because you won't put your faith in that
system you won't stand up for what you
truly believe in and and want
and so
we don't know what's going on with any
with the libertarian party we don't know
what's going on the republican party one
of the one of the challenges is that
there's no good party the democrats are
insane if you give them power they will
use it they will misappropriate it even
if you find one like all these moderate
democrats who are like we're going to
get back to kitchen table issues vote
for me and then people said okay and
they're like here pelosi here's here's
power yep okay so great you basically
just voted for pelosi what's the point
of that then you get the republicans and
what do you get when you go republican
they do nothing
nothing is better than burning the
system down i guess so
if that's your choice and then you have
the libertarian party
which is insane yeah they're just
they're just insane yeah the libertarian
party of texas tweeted you can't be
pro-freedom and anti-immigration and i'm
like that just doesn't even mean
anything you said nothing i'm not saying
it's wrong i'm saying it's not saying it
were it's like
you can't like pizza if you're a fan of
carrots what what are you talking about
attitude yeah the argument that you
can't have secure borders or community
makes literally no sense
it's like you're either an anarchist or
you're you're a nazi
no uh there's varying degrees in between
those two things my friend you can be
very pro-freedom but not an anarchist
libertarian party does not mean
anarchist it means there's some
government are those restrictions
anti-freedom it's just meaningless
garbage it doesn't mean anything
and i feel like most people who are
starting to pay attention to politics
are like can we just have like a guy to
you know do some maintenance on the
machine you know someone in government
is going to be like we'll get everything
going
the other thing too is
we're always writing up new laws
we're always complaining about things
have we ever stopped to consider that
like it's pretty going pretty pretty
well let's you know let's let's take a
breather
how about
for once we just kind of like have a
seat
just breathing it out a little bit no
it's always
get someone in
new laws more more laws in the book
stack them up stack them up stack them
they never go away
have you ever stopped to consider that
like you know it's going pretty well
i i i do but no
not really never i would love to see
that to see more uh what's the what's
the repellation of uh law yeah
i guess i guess the issue though is
there are certainly things that i think
need to change section 230 for instance
censorship stuff
you know so there's always there's
always something happening thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you